[Applause]
what a bad week for the activist press
Smollett Sandman Lara Logan and the
three Horsemen of the media apocalypse
they got every reporter pulling out
their hair well except for this guy I
think he's already moved onto his back
first there's Nick suing the Washington
Post for 250 million bucks it's a lot of
money but think about how much money
they made off smearing him the paper
makes a hundred million bucks off
digital ad sales alone that's a lot of
money a hundred million dollars that's
more than I make in a year how do they
make all that money conflict which
brings eyeballs which makes money so I
say Nick Sandman get your piece you
earned it without you how would Chris
Cuomo afford is daily waxing at least
daily now there's Smollett like
Covington it began with media ready
conflict spiraling into a hate tornado
directed at the usual suspects which is
you remember Covington was a white brat
in a red hat Smollett also tapped that
hat sadly it turns out his white racists
were Nigerian bodybuilders check out
this pair their abs have abs they got
more muscles than a mullahs convention
if I had access to those washboards I'd
be doing laundry every night of the week
Smollett paid them 3500 bucks to pull
off the stunt yet
he makes 60 grand a show so forget that
he's a hope stir he's just a cheap now
these cases along with the Brett
Kavanaugh smear they need to be part of
a course call it journalistic ethics
something to take instead of
intersectional gender studies and I know
who should teach it media everywhere is
mostly liberal not just in the US but in
this country eighty-five percent of
journalists are registered Democrats so
that's just a fact right and ones
registering Democrats when they're
rarely a Republican so the facts are on
the side of what you just stated most
journalists are are left or liberal or
Democrat mmm talk about speaking truth
to power which is why no one covered it
but us because when the news embarrasses
the news industry it disappears faster
than Taylor Swift's boyfriends because
once the emperor's new clothes are
exposed don't expect the Emperor to tell
you about it the emperor is busy blaming
fox for eating people's lunches Sean
Hannity is gonna eat justly small let's
lunch every single second Tucker Carlson
is going to eat justly small that's
lunch
every single second it up the President
of the United States is gonna eat his
lunch I'm getting hungry
so that's the concern we're gonna dine
on Smollett no lemon we're dining on you
you believed him because you already
believed all Trump supporters were
racists Smollett served a purpose for
you and you served a purpose for him
Smollett saw the media for what it was
suckers and I kind of admire it but if
your only lesson is that Smollett was
being used by us as fodder while missing
the fact that he made you look like a
dumbass then you truly are a lemon six
since 2016 these media fail moments have
been piling up and the same culprits are
at the scene of every crime it's the
activists
journalists driven by an agenda and the
profit maker behind this machine is
always conflict yeah I did the racial
slurs and maybe even some of the
homophobic slurs being used toward him
you can see how serious this crime is
right now absolutely despicable of
smollett in real life is black and gay
which may have been the motivation for a
possible hate crime against him in
Chicago I'm disgusted by people who wear
hats that seem Magga I don't believe
Jesse is making this up I don't like
that it's being put out there in the
media that this is a right possible
crime this is America in 2019 you wish
celebs also douve in placing the blame
where it belongs of course on pets it
was impossible to not feel this way
right now President and the Vice
President Mike Pence who like wishes I
couldn't be married let's just be clear
connect the dots this is what happens if
you are in a position of power and you
hate people and you want to cause
suffering to them you go through the
trouble you spend your career trying to
cause suffering what do you think is
gonna happen she should know I tried to
sit through her last movie that's
suffering
anyway I wonder if Colbert will have her
back on to discuss how pants didn't help
create a crime that didn't exist
meanwhile we all here held our tongues
even though the story stank like the
bathroom after curry night at the rest
home shrub I mean Trump supporters
stalking the Chicago streets and
sub-zero temperatures at 2:00 a.m.
carrying a noose running into some
nobody actor on a show they don't watch
and somehow recognizing him then beating
him up without taking his wallet phone
or sandwich this seemed it's possible as
me being hired as a babysitter they
didn't even take his sandwich it was a
subway and they're delicious
maybe that's mullets next gig subway
spokesman it's a step up from Jared by
the way he paid the Nigerians with a
check I mean who still writes checks
maybe your aunt on your birthday thanks
to thanks for the card at Edna and the
$10 but Smollett was the perfect victim
for a media that wanted this so badly to
be true so why are these hoaxes so
common here's my thinking all of those
folks who went to college in the last
decade or so are now employed in the
media and they brought with them the
victimhood virus they were infected with
on campus the virus makes you stupid
naive gullible did I say stupid yes I
did anyway some people are sad Smollett
was a hoax not me I've always thrilled
when a hate crime turns out to be false
which means I'm thrilled a lot it means
that we aren't as racists as the media
wants us to be and we live in a country
where hate crimes have to be made up
because the demand for hate crimes
exceeds the supply but if you're still
sad this was a hoax it's only because it
exposes how your activist bias set you
up as a willing stooge the media owns
this story it's like they took a course
on it
atención news professionals to the
traditions of objective reporting for
you are you hungry for the profits that
come with agenda driven headlines then
send your journalists to the blame
insinuate accused seminar now I'm gonna
show you some headlines and you're gonna
tell me how you would rewrite them for
maximum profit okay here's the first one
snowstorm expected to blanket northeast
White's
ski the rest freeze as snowstorm reveals
weather inequality nice here's another
one Midwest man wins Mega Millions
jackpot
oh man wins lottery no surprise to the
3.2 billion women didn't snappy I love
it Sally you're natural all right how
about this one world war two vet
celebrates 95th birthday elderly white
lifelong Republican voter turns 95
thanks to Russian collusion now all
right next one church youth group holds
bake sale for flood victims extremists
use religion to poison victims with
heart clogging toxins yes ok multi-car
accident on toronto freeway multi-car
accident on Toronto freeway only in
France American house fire in Australia
injure seven house fire in Australia
injure seven only in trumps America
volcano erupts in Brazil many injured
okay no erupts in Brazil many injured
only in trumps America yes you all
passed with flying colors I am so proud
of you now get out there and do some
journalism it's the blame insinuate
accused seminar locations everywhere
call today
[Applause]
good night's guess if your symptoms are
chronic
he's got the tonic host of the radio
show dr. true midday live dr. Drew
Pinsky
this man really got bin Laden to open up
former Navy SEAL Rob O'Neill feeling
crappy host of the tiresome tip podcast
got it
the last time he blew out birthday
candles they had to call the fire
department
former WWE Superstar dr. drew you're a
doctor or so you say I haven't actually
seen your diploma has America turned
into one big Church of victimhood what's
going on not only that we have such we
get such credibility from being a victim
people want to be a certain kind of
victim so badly we're actually seeing a
little epidemic of these kinds of hoaxes
they all have the same kind of construct
to them yeah which is people want to be
a victim of these things because it
gives them status right it's it's
actually for this guy it's better to be
a victim to that should be than being a
star of a show that's insane it's
strange how however I've been doing a
lot of thinking about this guy yeah and
he album dropping like a day after that
string and it was all about exactly what
happened to him in Chicago and I wonder
if there was some he would he even he
listened to this even he was shocked and
how crazy the media got with his story
yes I think that might be the case all
right Rob what's your take on this I am
a straight white kid from Butte Montana
who could probably be on the cover of
decent shame magazine so I have never I
have never been the victim of a hate
crime I've never seen it but for someone
it's one thing to screw up which I don't
think happened it's another thing to
make it happen a hoax like this that
takes away from actual hate crimes we're
real violence in Chicago there's a
problem real people who are gay or
transgender getting beat up it's a shame
because now is this real or is someone
making this up and I don't think
personally he did it like they're saying
for salary I think he did this because
he hated Trump so much maybe we can make
them all races to make people hate Trump
more it just it I mean it might sound
ridiculous but how ridiculous I'm
said he got beat up and held on to a
sandwich so that's yes I mean I've been
at fights before that's the first thing
I drop yeah although I would you I would
beat them with the meat well played sir
by the way that can't be bleak thank you
I'm being applauded for some strange
sentence no I'm just this whole thing
confuses me I love attention yes I love
it so much that it pushes people away
however I don't fake a racist homophobic
attack on myself love attention like
hasn't he heard of just like posting a
selfie on Instagram or like starting a
fight with your boyfriend or pretending
to be pregnant ah these are all better
ways or maybe like learning to ride a
unicycle because you know what that's
the only reason anyone learns to ride a
unicycle Greg that's true they have
invented bikes with two wheels that is
true that is true you we're gonna get
don't sit unicycle lowriders send the
letters to cats you're doing it for the
attention all four of you yes pirates
smearing the unicyclists tyrus what are
your thoughts uh besides the fact that
you literally great monologue by the way
thank you but you certainly got really
creepy in there literally every time you
made a great point he slid in something
creepy is anyone still stuck on the hold
oh me babysit your kids without a
mission a cry for help like kids gonna
beat the meet up myself
they're so insane like say something
like you know we should all be unified
together and then unifying my basement
like he's creepy things that's Mike this
is my segue we don't have the explosion
from you know tyrant imp that iceplug I
was talked to dr. drew a lot about this
dr. D said I call you that I was trying
to figure out why he did this why did
you give this and salary and this
whatever
and I've actually witnessed this
behavior quite often in my own life in
my own home mm-hm
four-year-old daughter really she'll be
running in the yard back and forth and
I'll be helping you work yeah maybe
watching the ESPN report on my phone or
whatever and she'll fall yeah Oh what
happened a shark will look at me and I'm
like a shark oh my poor baby and then I
gave her a hug and guess what yeah
where's the shark and I think they left
daddy I think we're good now so she just
wanted a hug he did this for hug yeah
you should have paid you should have
paid those guys 35 over to hug oh my god
[Applause]
we have to roll but I do believe that it
has a lot to do with naivete the people
in media right now are coming from the
campus and they can't everybody here dr.
drew Rob Rob military cat libertarian
tired your mouth tires streetwise none
of you believe this story none of you
believe this story but stop people that
work at MSNBC it's CNN in their
newsrooms bought it they bought it and
ran brim with exactly